you know occasionally I catch crap from
you people when some of you listen the
listening audience when I address
someone who's shacking up versus being
married and you think that I'm just
being overly bible-thumping or Christian
or something like that that could be
true I can be accused of those things
and that's fine and be guilty guilty as
charged
but why would that be why would I bother
and intersect your life on a personal
level like that when you're calling to
ask me about something else because it's
an economic problem really interesting
article this week in the Federalist
Federalist calm the Federalist calm if
you want to look up the article the
article says the research proves the
number one social justice imperative is
marriage I don't have time to go through
the whole article but this is just
really intriguing research says just 70
years ago social mobility and protection
from poverty were largely a factor of
employment those who had full-time work
of any kind were seldom poor 50 years
ago education marked the gulf separating
the haves and the have-nots for the last
20 years or more though marital status
has increasingly become the central
factor in whether our neighbors and
their children
rise above remain or descend into
poverty the research is astounding in
1960 the poorly and moderately educated
were only 10 percent less likely to be
married than the college-educated with
both numbers quite high 84 and 94
percent respectively that parity largely
held until the late 1970s ie the sexual
revolution by the way professor bill
Galston president of Clinton's President
Clinton's domestic policy advisor and
now I senior fellow at Brookings
explained that in the early 1990s that
an American need only to do three
- avoid living in poverty graduate from
high school marry before having a child
and have that child after age 20 only 8%
of the people who do so he reported will
be poor while 79 percent who do who fail
to do those all three will be poor if
you fail to do that wait till after 20
to have kids wait to have kids until
after you're married and graduate from
high school
you're 79% more likely to be in poverty
only 8% who follow the sequence are in
poverty you want to do away with poverty
get it in the right order that's what
the data shows graduate from high school
get married have a kid after you're
married after 20 those are the only
things you got to do and then you have a
92% likelihood you won't be in poverty
you have a 79% likelihood you will be in
poverty if you don't do it in that order
that's amazing
sociology us have referred to keeping
these things in proper order as the
success sequence it remains true
according to new research investigation
from Brookings and the American
Enterprise Institute takes a deeper look
at the first comes love then comes
marriage sequence by class and by
generation a recent report on this topic
focusing on Millennials reports that 97%
of those who follow the success sequence
earn at least a high school diploma work
and marry before having children will
not be poor as they enter their 30s this
is largely true for ethnic minorities
and those who grew up in poor families
but sadly fewer Millennials are keeping
these things in order compared to their
boomer and X or forbearers by the way if
you don't know the statistics side bar
more people now live together that are
not married then live together who are
married yeah if you're if you're old
enough to remember Leave It to Beaver
June and more cleaver they're dead okay
more people now shack up then not
interesting and it's the success
sequence the first comes love is so much
more than moral choice according this
article or romantic idealism these are
deeply pragmatic economic decisions
powerfully affecting class mobility
where people live on the social scale
and the opportunities they will be able
to provide for their children this is
because of the extraordinary economic
power of marriage the consistent and
irrefutable mountain of research has
shown reading reaching back to the 1970s
and beyond that marriage strongly boosts
every important measure of well-being
for children women and men pick any
measure you can imagine over all
physical and mental health income
savings employment educational success
general life contentment happiness
sexual satisfaction even recovery from
serious disease healthy diet and
exercise married people rate markedly
and consistently better in each of these
and so many more compared to their
single divorced and cohabitating peers
this thus marriage is an essential
active ingredient in improving one's
overall life prospects regardless of
class race or educational status that is
why it's not merely one parent versus
two parent families that make the
difference the US Census Bureau finds
that the poverty rate for children
living in poverty with two unmarried
cohabitating parents is similar to that
of single mother homes rather than those
that were married mother and father
married people regardless of how much
they have tend to manage their money
differently than divorced single and
cohabitating people this just goes on
and on and on and on where is it only
four percent of the homes with a married
mother and father are on food stamps but
21% of cohabitating and 28%
of single-mother homes are require such
public assistance there's a high
correlation between economically winning
and getting married before having
children graduating from high school and
having children after 20 these are
decisions you get to decide you're not a
victim of your choices you are a result
of your choices you get to decide these
things decide these things here's
another example did you know that you're
statistically very likely to stay
married if you're engaged at least six
months you want to add probability to
stay married engage six months and make
50,000 a year household income or
greater Oh add probability that four
years of education Oh add probability of
that pre marriage counseling in depth
not a drive-by one-hour session with the
preacher but I'm talking about in-depth
free marriage counseling where you talk
about her mama yeah you could change
this you can make decisions to change
your whole direction of your family tree
this marriage thing is real this is very
interesting very interesting the
Federalists calm the research proves the
number one social justice imperative is
marriage hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh